You see there are many different features we could have selected to build
this model.
For example, we could have looked at locations at different times.
For example, at 2 a.m.,
or 10 p.m.,
where a person is more like likely to be at their home.
We could also have used the (X, Y) co-ordinates instead of the distances.
Or we could have used a different distance metric.
Let's explore this a little bit further.
We could have taken the distance between point one and point two as the absolute
value of the differences between the X and Y co-ordinates of the two points.
Think about this distance function for a second.
Within cities, only crows and pigeons and
mostly birds can move in a straight line from point A to point B.
The rest of us, non-flying people, have to cover this particular distance.
This distance is called the Manhattan distance or the taxicab distance.
What features would you have chosen to solve this problem?
Pick a couple,
then use some of the techniques you have learned in lesson two to analyze them.
For example, you could calculate the information gain both for
the Euclidean distance we chose earlier and the Manhattan distance denoted here.
Check the box when you have done this.
This quiz is not graded.